und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und marietta slomka guten abend
damit beginnen wir
um entschuldigung irgendwie ist meiner
regie hat ein bisschen aufgeregt
ok also eigentlich wollte mit der
gasanlage anfangen aber die ist noch
nicht da machen wir mit einem anderen
thema erweitern es ist zwar für uns alle
nur ein schwacher trost aber stichwort
gaskrise anderswo läuft auch nicht gut
großbritannien etwa bezieht zwar kaum
gas aus russland leidet aber auch unter
explodierenden energiepreisen und auch
in großbritannien sucht man nach
instrumenten um einerseits die
verbraucher vor unbezahlbaren rechnungen
zu schützen und andererseits zu
verhindern dass gas und stromversorger
pleite gehen dazu muss man wissen dass
es in großbritannien einen preis decke
gibt der das jährliche maximum festlegt
dass ein privater durchschnittshaushalt
für strom und gas ausgeben muss das
bestimmt eine regulierungsbehörde
dieser deckel wurde jetzt massiv
angehoben und das entsetzen ist groß
berichtet michael haselrieder aus london
in robins lebt im osten londons die
kosten für strom und die gasheizung sind
so stark gestiegen dass er ein drittel
seines einkommens dafür ausgeben muss es
bleibt wenig geld zum leben der 57
jährige sucht deshalb nach alternativen
ich habe noch einen kaminofen hier
eigentlich sollten wir keine fossilen
brennstoffe wie kohle mehr nutzen aber
wenn wir dadurch unsere räume wärmen
können ohne die gasheizung anzustellen
dann werden wir das häufig tun
die preise für gas und strom werden im
herbst weiter steigen um 80 prozent die
unabhängige britische
regulierungsbehörde hat heute eine neue
obergrenze festgesetzt bisher können
energieversorger umgerechnet 2300 30
euro pro jahr von einem
durchschnittshaushalt verlangen ab
oktober sind es dann
4200 euro
ipswitch im osten englands viele
haushalte fürchten dass es im winter für
sie
highstreet zu deutsch essen oder heizen
marina sucht hilfe bei einer
beratungsstelle sie hat longo witt und
ihren job als krankenpflegerin verloren
um strom zu sparen sitzt sie zu hause
oft im dunkeln sagt sie
jeden tag habe ich angst wie ich
weiterleben soll
ich habe mir eigentlich gedacht dass ich
in meinem alter mir keine gedanken mehr
darüber machen muss und einfach normal
leben kann
die ärmsten trifft die krise am
härtesten
trotzdem will beust johnson keine
zusätzlichen entlastungen für die bürger
auf den weg bringen und das der
nachfolgeregierung überlassen
leider hat die britische regierung
keinerlei vorsorge getroffen um auf
diese starke erhöhung der energiepreise
zu reagieren wir befinden uns im grunde
in einem vakuum und das schon seit
wochen
denn so lange suchen die konservativen
schon nach einem neuen premier das duell
zwischen außenministerin lesters und
ex-finanzminister regisseur nach dauert
noch bis anfang september so lange will
den robbens nicht warten er hat sich wie
etwa 120.000 andere briten einer
kampagne angeschlossen ihre strom- und
gasrechnungen einfach nicht zu zahlen
dann per uk das vertrauen in die politik
hat er verloren zwei termine das ist wie
bei der titanic die auf den eisberg
zusteuert und der kapitän ist nicht auf
der brücke keiner unternimmt politisch
irgendwas und zu versuchen den schaden
der entstehen wird zu begrenzen um den
zusammenstoß zu vermeiden
los geht s sowie hunderttausenden
anderen dritten sie wissen nicht wie sie
durch diesen winter kommen sollen
sie haben wir beschäftigen uns in
deutschland ja auch das habe ihm die
letzten 48 stunden den tag ganz schön
versagt sagt der robert habeck heute und
das glaubt man ihm sofort aus der
vermurksten gas umlage kommt er nämlich
nicht so leicht wieder heraus die sache
ist komplex einerseits sollen die
gaspreise steigen und sonst spart keine
und der verbrauch geht nicht zurück
andererseits sollen wichtige versorger
nicht in die knie gehen wir erinnern uns
aus der finanzkrise ja noch an den
begriff systemrelevant es sollten aber
ja auch nicht die falschen profitieren
und an der stelle wird es knifflig auch
juristisch und diese so genannten
mitnahmeeffekte fallenden minister nun
krachend auf die füße gestellt heute
änderungen in aussicht klingt aber noch
nicht so als habe er da schon einen plan
die anfrage berichtet
bislang war er einer der gewinner dieser
koalition robert habeck in umfragen
beliebt und von beobachtern gepriesen
für seine klare kommunikation
doch ausgerechnet der
wirtschaftsminister gerät in diesen
tagen zunehmend in erklärungsnot
ein befreiungsschlag bei der gasanlage
gelingt ihm auch heute nicht zumindest
zeigte er sich offen noch einmal nach zu
schärfen
deswegen schauen wir ob es ohne dass die
umlage insgesamt gefährdet wird und
unter wahrung des gleichheitsgrundsatzes
möglichkeiten gibt rechtssichere
möglichkeiten gibt diese
trittbrettfahrer wieder auszusortieren
das außer angeschlagenen unternehmen wie
juniper auch gasversorger von der umlage
profitieren könnten die in anderen
sparten milliardengewinne machen sorgt
weiter für heftige kritik selbst aus der
eigenen partei steht habeck unter
beschuss meinen augen sollten sich
dringend in der ampel darum bemühen dass
man das ganze so gestaltet dass die
firmen die erhebliche gewinne
einfahren und deshalb die gasanlage
nicht brauchen dass die dienst regan
immer genervt auch die eigenen
koalitionspartner die wollen bald das
dritte entlastungspaket präsentieren und
haben die dauerdiskussion über die
umlage satt es darf nicht sein dass
weder mit mit mitteln der der kunden
oder kundinnen oder auch mit
steuermitteln unternehmen unterstützt
werden die diese unterstützung nicht
brauchen es ist die aufgabe des
wirtschaftsministers dieses problem zu
lösen denn die konstruktion hat er
vorgeschlagen und die erwartungshaltung
die existiert ist das hier eine
vernünftige
funktionierende umlage existiert und
diese umlage ist derzeit nicht
funktioniert die union will die umlage
lieber ganz loswerden und schlägt vor
der staat solle sich noch stärker als
bisher bei insolvenz bedrohten
unternehmen beteiligen klar ist der
juniper als gashändler muss gestützt
werden um auch versorgungssicherheit für
gas kunden zu geben die frage ist nur
wie es gibt bessere wege etwa direkt
über den bundeshaushalt
gezielt ein unternehmen zu stützen das
finanzielle probleme hat und nicht
gleich alle selbst die mit gewinnen auch
zu stützen
wirtschaftsexperten warnen davor sich in
der diskussion nur auf die gasanlage zu
konzentrieren der gaspreis habe sich
bereits vervielfacht die bundesregierung
müsse für umfassende entlastungen sorgen
es muss ein überzeugendes entlastungs
paket auf den tisch die zusätzlichen
belastungen werden mehrere tausend euro
pro haushalt betragen insofern ist es
nicht mit einmalzahlung von 300 euro de
getan der druck auf robert habeck die
ungeliebte umlage endlich zu korrigieren
wächst genau wie der auf die gesamte
regierung ein schlüssiges
entlastungskonzept vorzulegen
[Musik]
und zu dem ganzen themenkomplex
energiekrise und gasversorgung finden
sie bei uns auch online umfängliche
informationen von politischen
hintergründen bis zu ganz konkreten
verbrauchertipps darauf zdf folgt
und dann klicken wenn die ukraine wo ein
atomkraftwerke ja zur kriegsbeute
geworden ist was inzwischen zu fast
täglich neuen beunruhigenden meldungen
für cordula in der ukraine ist das
russisch besetzte atomkraftwerks aprilia
nach der notabschaltung wieder am netz
präsident selensky sagte europa sei nur
knapp einer katastrophe entgangen er
forderte dringend aufklärung und eine
zügige inspektion des akw durch experten
der internationalen atomenergiebehörde
die lenski warf russland erneut vor das
akw beschossen zu haben was zu der
stromunterbrechung geführt habe ein
russischer vertreter nannte einen nicht
näher definierten brand als ursache
die verkehrsminister der länder fordern
ein nachfolgemodell für das am mittwoch
auslaufende 9 euro ticket und zugleich
deutlich mehr geld vom bund für den
öffentlichen nahverkehr
nach einer sondersitzung mit den
länderkollegen bezeichnete
bundesverkehrsminister wissing die
forderungen als enttäuschend auch die
länder seien in der pflicht als erstes
bundesland will berlin das neun euro
ticket bis jahresende verlängern
sparmaßnahmen in der asylpolitik haben
in den niederlanden zu untragbaren
zuständen vor einem überfüllten
asylzentrum geführt vor diesem
hintergrund hat ein zuständiger
staatssekretär am abend angekündigt die
niederlande würden vorerst keine
weiteren flüchtlinge mehr aufnehmen wozu
sie sich aber laut vertrag mit der
türkei verpflichtet hatten in tempel an
der grenze zu niedersachsen halten sich
hunderte menschen vor der zentralen
anlaufstelle für asylsuchende auf viele
campieren dort und schlafen im freien
die hygienischen zustände seien
katastrophal berichten hilfsorganisation
bewohner protestierten gegen die
überforderung der gemeinde durch das
asylzentrum
das us justizministerium hat auf
anordnung eines richters ein dokument zu
den ermittlungen gegen ex präsident
trump veröffentlicht dabei geht es um
die durchsuchung seines privaten
anwesens in florida wo weitere als
streng geheim oder vertraulich
eingestufte dokumente gefunden worden
waren in dem in großen teilen
geschwärzten dokument wird auch der
anfangsverdacht des fbi beschrieben
trump habe gesetzeswidrig vertrauliche
dokumente aus dem weißen haus
mitgenommen
pakistan hat wegen anhaltender heftiger
regenfälle und schwere überschwemmungen
den notstand ausgerufen
die regierung bat wegen der fluten um
internationale hilfe nach angaben der
nationalen katastrophenbehörde haben
fast 1000 menschen in den fluten ihr
leben verloren von den hochwassern seien
33 millionen menschen schwer betroffen
pakistan leidet seit mitte juni unter
ungewöhnlich starken monsunregen
in vielen hauptstädten europas hätte man
sich gewünscht dass mario draghi
italienische regierungschef bleibt viele
fanden er sei das beste was italien
seite lang und passiert war ein
verlässlicher nicht dollar profi der
seinem land auf internationaler bühne zu
neuem gewicht verhalf aber nach 522
tagen erging es super mario diese ihnen
in italien nennen nicht viel besser als
vielen seiner vorgänger die
regierungskoalition zerbrach am 25
september gibt es jetzt neuwahlen und
nach aktuellen umfragen haben die
rechtspopulisten wieder einmal die nase
vorn diesmal angeführt von einer frau
giorgia meloni wer sie ist und was sie
ankündigt ein porträt von annette
hilsenbeck
seid ihr bereit es ist der
wahlkampfslogan von georgia meloni die
gute chancen hat ministerpräsidentin zu
werden umfragen sehen ihre partei
fratelli d'italia mit über 24 prozent
als stärkste kraft in ancona schwirrt
sie ihre anhänger auf einen sieg ein
ich sage euch ehrlich ich denke ich kann
eine solche regierung führen
wir sind italiener ich bin bereit das zu
verteidigen ihm wert zu geben weil ich
das land lieber
meloni positionen nationalistisch ihre
themen kirche vaterland und familie dazu
eine harte anti migrationspolitik und
widerstand gegen einfluss aus brüssel
vor rund einem jahr noch erklärte sie in
einer talkshow eu und euro neu
diskutieren zu wollen
ich halte es nicht aus dass man als
ketzer behandelt wird als fand die
europäer bloß weil man eine andere
vorstellung von europa hat
und ich glaube auch der euro sollte neu
verhandelt werden zu sagen dass der
nicht geändert werden kann dass es nicht
in unserem interesse
nun im wahlkampf erklärt sie sich an eu
haushaltsregeln zu halten trotz
wahlkampf versprechen steuersenkungen
rentenerhöhungen
ihr sieg wäre ein starker rechtsruck in
italien meloni fratelli d'italia ist aus
der postfaschistischen bewegung
hervorgegangen beim singen der
nationalhymne ist auch mal der römischen
brust zu sehen denn die faschisten
nutzten
toshiba will wiedeking dem motto
faschismus bedeutet dass ein aufruf zu
den traditionellen werten gott vaterland
und familie gibt sehen wir vereinfachen
wollen
aber das bedeutet auch dass es da auch
randgruppen gibt
in italien ist das anders als in
deutschland weil man in italien
vielleicht noch nicht ganz die
faschistische vergangenheit verarbeitet
hat ron barcelo verschiesst
die macht bei fratelli d'italia ist auf
giorgia meloni zentriert wer sonst zur
führungsriege gehört bleibt lückenhaft
ebenso welche kräfte die parteilinken
die starken kräfte die hinter den
fratelli d'italia stehen wenn es welche
gibt sind im moment nicht sichtbar das
wird man erst noch sehen denn sie haben
ja nie regiert
die wahl gewinnen würde meloni auch dank
ihres stabilen mitte rechts bündnisses
zu dem auch berlusconis forza italia und
matteo salvini ist leger gehören
außenpolitisch könnte sich da ein
spannungsfeld auftun berlusconi und sein
wenig verlegten stets enge beziehungen
zu putins russland giorgia meloni
bekennt sich jedoch zur nato unterstützt
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine
ich habe mich zu diesem
waffenlieferungen die in der
öffentlichkeit keinen anklang finden
diejenigen die denken dass wir das
problem gelöst haben wenn sich die
ukraine ergeben sehen doch zu kurz
es sind noch 30 tage bis zur wahl
verhalten die umfragen recht bleibt die
stimmung könnte italien mit ihr einen
rechtsruck erleben der auch europa
verändern könnte
der gestürzte mario draghi hatte sich ja
seinerseits seinerzeit sofort und
eindeutig an die seite der ukraine
gestellt und sich für ihren beitritt zur
eu stark gemacht
ob das unter neuer italienische
regierung so bleibt muss zumindest
fraglich und diese unsicherheit wird man
im kreml mit zufriedenheit zur kenntnis
nehmen für maske ist jede politische
instabilität in europa ein gewinn und
dabei ist das russische regime ja
keineswegs nur passiver zuschauer seit
jahren verbreitet moskau propaganda und
fake news in westlichen ländern und
unterstützt europas populisten
insbesondere jene am rechten rand die
kontakte sind vielfältig eine klinik
berichtet
einmal in der woche meldet sich
russlands chef propagandist kisseljow zu
wort und gibt die richtung vor die von
einer autobombe getötete journalistin
dugena ist eine heldin eine märtyrerin
gezeigt wird wie die nationalistische
krawall reporterin mit der russischen
armee durch das lang umkämpfte stahlwerk
in mariupol läuft begeistert vom kampf
russland gegen die ukraine
dass die patriot in china in frankreich
studierte und dort ganz im sinne des
kreml kontakt zur rechtsextremen
politikern aufnahmen erfährt der
fernsehzuschauer nicht
die liaison zwischen dem kreml und der
äußersten rechten in europa hat
tradition marine le pen trifft sich
schon 2017 mit wladimir putin ihren
wahlkampf finanziert sie auch mit dem
kredit einer kremlnahen bank russland
hegt sympathien für die italienische
lega nord unterstützt den
hauptprotagonisten des black sydney
geoffrey rush und auch die deutsche fdp
bekommt termine in moskau alice weidl
trifft sich mit parlamentariern
parteichef kruppa mit russlands
außenminister sergei lavrov das motiv
des kreml ist klar europas spaltung
es geht darum politische kräfte in der
eu zu stärken die die politischen
systeme der eu-mitgliedstaaten und
natürlich auch die eu selbst in ihren
grundfesten in frage stellen und das
ziel das damit verbunden ist ist die
europäische union als
integrationsprojekt von innen heraus zu
schwächen anti eu antiliberal
antidemokratisch gegen gender waren und
für die traditionelle familie gegen
einwanderung positionen wie sie zum
beispiel viktor orban vertritt werden
von putins ideologen geteilt und
gefördert russland und sein starker
führer in rechten kreisen eine
verheißung putin selber hat sich
entwickelt zu einem rechtspopulistischen
führer von durban steht der nähe er hat
in seiner rede am 22
februar auch von blut und boden
gesprochen dh er benutzt auch zum teil 1
versatzstücke rechtsextreme ideologie
der krieg jedoch bedeutet eine
zerreißprobe denn auch rechte kräfte
bewundern den patriotischen kampf der
ukraine putins anziehung droht zu
verblassen wäre da nicht die
energiekrise die von populisten von
rechts und links genutzt wird die fdp
ist schon mal zum kampf konkret heißt
das dass wir diesen wirtschaftskrieg
beenden müssen russland sanktionen
stoppen und endlich
friedensverhandlungen fördern damit wir
aus dieser sackgasse aus dieser einmal
straße auch hinauskommen und so könnte
sich moskaus engagement für die rechten
in europa doch noch auszahlen der kreml
drosselt die gaszufuhr und hilft damit
den kräften die europa spalten wollen
putins strategie könnte aufgehen
wirtschaft geht es weiter gut gelaunt da
erst noch mal um die gaspreise
die europäischen gaspreise steigen und
steigen aktuell auf ein rekordhoch die
sorge ist groß dass die gaslieferungen
aus russland ganz ausbleiben weil real
an der börse wie erklärt sich eigentlich
der aktuelle deutliche sprung der
gaspreis eben genau aus dieser angst
heraus vor einem lieferstopp aus
russland die nächste wartung an der
gaspipeline nord stream 1 steht ja an am
31 august für drei tage nach der letzten
wurde die liefermenge ja auf 20 prozent
gedrosselt klar fragt man sich da wie
viel gas ab kommender woche aus russland
überhaupt noch zu erwarten ist bei
gazprom hingegen da sind die lager voll
zu voll nahe der finnischen grenze ist
eine riesige orangefarbene flamme zu
sehen gas das für den europäischen markt
bestimmt war wird hier abgefackelt
gängige praxis in der gasproduktion
nicht aber in solchen mengen schätzungen
zufolge könnte russland hier gas im wert
von bis zu 10 millionen euro am tag
verbrennen auch ein umweltproblem weil
dabei natürlich auch sehr viel co2
freigesetzt wird der gaspreis in europa
jedenfalls ist heute um rund zehn
prozent hochgeschossen das andere große
finanz thema ist die us zinspolitik fed
chef paul hat auch an der frankfurter
börse nervosität ausgelöst wie das weil
man davon ausgeht dass es auch in europa
einen ganz großen zinsschritt geben
könnte us notenbankchef paul hat die
finanzmärkte
unmissverständlich auf einen langen
kampf gegen die inflation eingestimmt
das klingt nach deutlichen
zinserhöhungen
ja und wenn die amerikanische notenbank
so forsch vorprescht dann kommt auch die
ezb unter druck stärker aufs gaspedal zu
drücken paul hielt seine rede übrigens
bei der notenbanker konferenz in wyoming
dem weltweit wichtigsten geldpolitischen
treffen des jahres ezb chefin lagarde
nicht daran teil in zeiten derart hoher
inflation und rezessionssorgen kann man
sich da nur wundern vielen dank valerie
für den umfassenden blick auf die märkte
als ein zeugnis der klimakrise hat
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister ärzte mir
die neue erntebilanz bezeichnet die
licht und schatten zeige trotz der
trockenheit wurde etwas mehr raps und
winterweizen eingefahren körnermais
dagegen leidet extrem unter der willst
du mir forderte die bäuerinnen und
bauern auf sich schnell dem klimawandel
anzupassen und zugleich den
klimafreundlichen umbau der
landwirtschaft voranzutreiben dafür so
die kritik aus der union fehle ein
gesamtkonzept
deutsche haushalte haben im vergangenen
jahr durchschnittlich 23 prozent des
einkommens für wohnkosten aufgebracht
nach angaben des statistischen
bundesamtes waren 10 7 prozent der
bevölkerung wegen dieser ausgaben
überlastet diese definition gilt wenn
man über 40 prozent des verfügbaren
einkommens für miete oder kredit abtrag
ausgeben muss in der fußball bundesliga
hat am abend der vierte spieltag
begonnen der sc freiburg hatte den vfl
bochum zu gast die partie ist gerade
eben zu ende gegangen gewonnen hat
freiburg 1 0 und der deutsche
wetterdienst warnt vor schweren
gewittern zur stunde in allen
ostdeutschen bundesländern sowie in
teilen von niedersachsen
ehrenamtliche seien der größte schatz
den deutschland zu bieten hat so
bedankte sich bundespräsident steinmeier
bei allen engagierten im land und den
1500 die zum bürgerfest ins schloss
bellevue gekommen waren das fest wurde
diesmal vor allem jugendlichen gewidmet
die sich einsetzen obwohl sie besonders
unter der korona krise gelitten haben
wegen drohender unwetter musste das fest
am frühen abend vorzeitig abgebrochen
werden morgen soll schloss bellevue
wieder für alle geöffnet sein
wer bei dem namen als erstes an einen
texaner mit cowboyhut und gemeinem
lachen denkt hat definitiv die 80er
erlebt der gea von dem bei uns jetzt die
rede ist ist allerdings ein anderer und
kunstkenner wissen natürlich auch schon
wer gemeint ist die a der französische
bank sie ein street ates der unter
pseudonym arbeitet und über sich wenig
bis nichts verrät aber immerhin begegnen
kann man barbara lueg hat ihn in münchen
getroffen anlässlich der eröffnung einer
großen retrospektive seines werkes
bekannt ist er für seine großflächigen
fotografien die im öffentlichen raum
platziert wie in berlin oder auch am
pariser louvre längst ist er mit solchen
aktionen hochwillkommen angefangen hatte
alles mit einer heimlichen nacht und
nebel aktion
kunst ist leben
[Musik]
und leben ist kunst
da wo der puls schlägt ist er auf der
straße für die straße hier entsteht
alles der öffentliche raum wird für den
shooting star der kunstszene zur
leinwand für alle
zusammen drehen wir die welt von innen
nach außen
kommt im hipster look nach münchen wie
gewohnt mit hut und sonnenbrille und
seiner mission
muss immer zur kommunikation führen der
prozess dahin ist das herzstück meiner
arbeit
jazz geschichte beginnt im außenbezirk
von paris er ist als sprayer unterwegs
als ihr schwere unruhen beginnen
er fotografiert die ghetto kids und
klebt ihre porträts nachts an die wände
der wohlhabenden innenstadtviertel
ein foto geht um die welt der junge mann
zielt auf den betrachter mit einem
camcorder das bild bis jazz durchbruch
stars herangehensweise ist eine ganz
andere
denn er fährt jetzt zu den menschen
kommt erstmal mit den menschen in
kontakt entwickelt mit den menschen
gemeinsam die geschichte die erzählt
werden soll
mit der großen wucht seiner bilder
erzählt die ausstellung von jazz
visionen von seinen projekten über denen
immer die für ihn wichtigste frage
schwebt kann kunst die welt verändern
in der petition
er reist nach israel und in die
palästinensergebiete sucht menschen auf
beiden seiten die behörden lassen ihn
gewähren am ende kleben gemeinsame fotos
von israelis und palästinensern an der
grenzmauer und die menschen kommen ins
gespräch
wer bin ich zu sagen ich wähle nur die
vermeintlich guten für meine projekte
aus auf diese weise sind alle menschen
teil der gemeinschaft
das ist seine große stärke als 50
menschen zu verbinden ihnen eine stimme
zu geben
tausende versammelten sich hier in den
sogenannten tor nichols um ihre
geschichte zu erzählen die die
ausstellungsbesucher mit hilfe einer
gesichtserkennung sap hören sollen
hey ich bin wendy und komme aus brooklyn
wisst ihr was gestern war mein
geburtstag
am ende zieht es ja wieder auf die
straße ein foto von valeria aus der
ukraine wird entrollt die frage bleibt
auch heute kann kunst die welt verändern
wohl kaum aber unseren blick auf sie
ganz sicher
[Musik]
das wasser muss gleich nach dem wetter
geht es musikalisch weiter mit
stargeiger david garrett und einer
wünsche oslo vor antica kulisse und um
0.40 melde ich mich wieder mit unserem
heute-journal update bis dahin ist
morgen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum wetter heute gab
es keinen gleichmäßigen landregen wie
wir ihn bräuchten um die dürre
nachhaltig zu entspannen sondern es
brodelten gewitter in schwüler und in
heißer luft heute morgen gab es zunächst
mal im westen etwas hochnebel und diese
wolken einer kaltfront die kam aber nur
langsam voran dafür schossen die
gewitterwolken in die höhe teilweise
innerhalb von minuten und die regen
signale zeigen uns schon das war heute
ein richtiger flickenteppich orte mit
platzregen direkt neben orten an denen
kein tropfen regen fiel jetzt aktuell
sieht doch ein gewitter komplex i aus
ostsachsen zu auch südöstlich von
hamburg blitzt und donnert ist noch
kräftig und genau diese zelle hier über
lüneburg sagt dafür dass bleckede
walmsburg in unserer regenmengen liste
für heute auf platz zwei steht mit 68
litern pro quadratmeter platz eins
belegt der flughafen berlin brandenburg
mit 82 liter pro quadratmeter
und dass es mehr als hier im
durchschnitt im ganzen august fällt und
zum vergleich berlin marzahn nur wenige
kilometer entfernt hier fielen nur 13
liter pro quadratmeter
mit diesen großen unterschieden geht es
jetzt auch in der nacht weiter denn die
gewitter sind sehr ortsfest und bewegen
sich nur langsam dann ist vor allem
starkregen das problem mit über 60
litern pro quadratmeter in kurzer zeit
die gefahr nimmt insgesamt im vergleich
zum tag etwas ab ist heute nacht im
osten und im süden des landes aber noch
vorhanden in den westen und nordwesten
da fließt mit einem frischen
nordwestlichen wind von der nordsee
schon etwas stabilere luft ein das ganze
bei 13 bis 19 grad heute nacht morgen
brodelt es dann im osten und im süden
weiter örtlich noch mal heftig mit
starkregen und überschwemmungsgefahr so
langsam setzen sich von nordwesten dann
aber die grösseren wolkenlücken durch
und dazu ist das mal ein tag ohne große
hitze bei 20 bis 26 grad ist es kühler
und angenehmer als zuletzt diese
temperaturen setzten sich auch noch bis
zum montag fort am dienstag wird es aus
südwesten dann schon wieder heißer es
gibt hin und wieder noch mal schauer und
gewitter am sonntag zum beispiel
richtung oder und richtung alpen
größtenteils setzt aber eine
wetterberuhigung ein und hiermit wünsche
ich ihnen noch eine ruhige nacht